the amount of international minimizing
of the atrocities committed by Hamas and
almost celebration using the paragliders
that descended on that music festival
where 260 people were killed many of
whom were teenagers and young adults uh
many of whom were tourists International
um you know foreign Nationals the
celebration of these murderous Hamas
paragliders and co-opting this image for
poster art done by black lives matter
organiz ations in the United States
distributed on college campuses All Over
America has been so disturbing to watch
I mean I live in New York City and
watching people congregate in Times
Square and making horribly anti-semetic
comments these cheers and jeers some of
these tweets that we're seeing and I
sort of trust people to be their worst
selves on the internet but you see many
people many Ultra Ultra online leftists
academics saying things along the lines
trying to map all of this onto this very
simplistic colonizer um oppressed
narrative uh you know this one tweet I
think is so emblematic of this mindset
what did y'all think decolonization
meant Vibes papers essays losers um and
it's like well wait a second like you
could reasonably oppose the actions of
the state of Israel and you could oppose
the way that they're leveling um so much
of Gaza while still saying that the
instigating attack what Hamas did of
putting bullet holes into children into
babies uh and executing grandmothers in
front of their families abducting people
you know there there's a little bit of
misinformation sort of floating around
and it's hard to sus out the extent to
which rape was used uh especially on
some of the uh women who were abducted
from that music festival the degree to
which you know peaceful kutes had you
know all kinds of Slaughter and and I
mean these are highly trusting
communities where generally speaking
you're prepared for Air Raids but not on
the ground attacks you had you know
neighbors watching their their neighbors
and family members being murdered I just
the amount of totally ignorant if not
outright evil vitriol we are seeing
spewed from so many corners of the
American Progressive left has been
highly disturbing to watch and I do I'm
curious about whether we're seeing a
little bit of this watershed moment a
little bit of a Reckoning where there's
a sense of like well wait a second
weren't you the same people on College
campuses complaining about
microaggressions and asking to be taken
into a safe space and like how do you
think this makes Jewish students on
these University campuses feel when you
were acting like these paragliders
should be used in your little canva
graphic design template I mean it's
pretty despicable to me also the left
has been so quick to you you know to
call everybody Nazis yeah you
know right and and and now and now we
see the largest mass killing you Jews
literally since the Holocaust and
they're coming out and marching um for
them for on the side um of the
perpetrators uh what what typically
happens when a group uses you know
Carnage against civilians in such an
overwhelming way is it not only reduces
the likelihood of government concessions
but it does tend to um international
support but in the case of the
Palestinians um we're not seeing the
standard um International effect it's
very hard to imagine a bloodletting like
this happening somewhere else in the
world and you know so many people all
over the place in America in Europe and
Australia Etc um you know holding up
signs and saying that this is Justified
and that this this is actually good and
maybe we should see uh even more of it
um so uh that this has been you know a
secondary very disturbing aspect of the
October 7th terrorist Rampage yeah and I
think Liz is right to say that there's
the sort of simplistic oppressor
oppressed lens that so many of these
activists have been acclimated to seeing
everything through and there's just this
sort of reflexive oh Palestine uh no
matter what the facts on the ground are
that's that's the side that we need to
you know align with uh before we wrap
this up I say you know just as just as
how governments sometimes support you
know terrorist groups and they think
that it will serve them well somehow and
then it ends up sort of backfiring
against the government these problems
that we're
seeing you know who's implicated in them
is actually the administrations at a lot
of these
universities where they hired
faculty um which contributed to the
radicalization um of the students and
they also built up these big Dei offices
which in frankly in many cases and this
is objectively true Based on data um
that more often than not they're
actually anti-semitic they don't even
really view Jews as a minority group
worth
protecting um and what's happened is
we've seen a radicalization of the youth
in this country particularly at the
universities and this could get out of
control in a way that the
administrations will regret but make no
mistake it's not a coincidence that the
radicalization um is happening at a lot
of these universities and I think that
the um administrations are largely
responsible for it even if they come to
regret that stance of theirs over the
last few years it's just objectively
true that hamas's
tactics in in many ways looked
absolutely as evil and barbaric as Isis
tactics um I've looked I've looked at
the pictures of I can verify them like
the the pictures of the burned babies
and going house to house and
shooting um families and this would you
would think
that this might be a bridge too far for
a lot of people that even if they
support the Palestinian cause they would
be repulsed by this level of
violence you never saw big
celebrations around the world after Isis
you know burnings and shootings and
beheadings you didn't see that out of
Australia or across cities in in America
or or in Europe but you do see a
celebration of the violence of
Hamas and so Hamas is more popular even
around the world than Isis ever was and
it somehow seemed as more acceptable to
sell Hamas violence around the world
than it ever was to sell celebrate Isis
violence you know you do not have to go
far from where I live or probably from
where either of you might be to
find Gatherings of Highly
activated uh upset activists who hold
signs which in many cases are lauding
not only the cause of the Palestinian
resistance but even the very disgusting
tactics against Israeli citizens on top
of that we know that according to the
latest number I saw Hamas killed
Internationals Hamas killed 22 Americans
and has an old told number of American
hostages and America is not alone these
aren't just just you know American
Israel citizens these are um foreigners
from from Asia for example Le um where
they were killed in in in numbers um and
so and again the Hamas attack is being
applauded by Al-Qaeda hey thanks for
watching that clip from our conversation
with Max Abrams about hamas's attack on
Israel for another clip click here for
the full conversation click here